[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم يقال من شابه اباه فما ظلم هذا
هو حال المستشرق الروسي الشهير البروفيسور
ميخائيل بتروسكي مدير متحف الارميتاج احد
اكبر المتاحف في العالم والذي يقال انك
تحتاج لخمسه اعوام كي تعرف ما يحتوي ورث
الرجل حب الاثار والاستشراق والانشغال
بالثقافه العربيه من ابي فورسكي عالم
المصريات الشهير والذي كان ايضا مديرا
لمتحف الارميتاج في مفارقه تجعله من هذه
الاسره امينه على ميراث روسيا القيصريه
والسوفيتيه والوطنيه المعاصره
عام 44 في العاصمه الارمنيه
بجامعه النيران التي اوفدته لمصر ضمن دوره
تدريبيه بجامعه القاهره ليصبح بعد ذلك
باحثا لدى اكاديميه العلوم السوفيتيه نال
عامه 73 الدكتوره عن اطروحاته التي تناولت
قصه الملك الحميري اسعد الكامل ثم توجه
الى جمهوريه اليمن الديمقراطيه الشعبيه
حيث عاملما ومدرسا لتاريخ اليمن بالمدرسه
العليا للعلوم الاجتماعيه عكف على دراسه
جزيره العرب واهتم بالعلاقه بين الحضرتين
بالجاهليه والاسلاميه وترجم الدراساته
الكثيره الى اللغه العربيه عام 84 اعد
بتروسكي اطروحه الدكتوراه ثانيه موضوعها
جنوب الجزيره العربيه في مطلع القرون
الوسطى ولضيفنا اعمالهم في التاريخ
السياسي الاسلامي والثقافه العربيه واثار
شبه الجزيره العربيه ما يجعل منه خبيرا
حقيقيا في التاريخ والفنون والحضاره
الاسلاميه نال العديد من الجوائز والاوسمه
ومنح الجائزه الرئاسيه في مجال الفني
والادب وجائزه الدوله في روسيا لمساهمه في
الحفاظ على التراث الثقافي الوطني
عام 97 اطلق الاتحاد الفلكي على كوكب صغير
اسم بتروفسكي تكريما مشترك لميخائيل
ووالده فورس بتروفسكي وفي عام 2011 تخب
عضوا في مجلس الدومه الروسي لكنه تخلى عن
المنصب لاحقا وقد كان وضعه على لائحه
الحزب الحاكم في الانتخابات محاوله ذكيه
للاستفاده من اسمه اللامع في الاوساط
الروسيه مشاهدينا الكرام البروفيسور
ميخائيل بتروفسكي المستشرق الروسي البارز
ومدير متحف الارميتاج ضيف المقابله هذا
المساء فاهلا ومرحبا بكم
[موسيقى]
اهلا بك يا دكتور
في هذا المتحف الذي نشات فيه اسرتك وتراسه
والدك وانت اليوم تراسه الارميتاج
قلب النابض لروسيا ولهذه الثقافه الروسيه
ماذا يوجد لدينا هنا دكتور
الروسيه وقضيه جورج وسوف
تحدثنا عن المقتنيات هناك مقتنيات من كل
دول العالم اريد ان اتحدث عن المقتنيات
الاسلاميه
ما هو ابرزها ما الذي يوجد منها في
العربيه
الهنديه الكبيره
المجوهرات المغنيه الملكيه موجوده عندنا
اشياء من البلور الحجري القطعه من فتره
الفاطميه
بالتماثيل اييه سوره الطيور والحيوان
مستخدمه في
الماء ولل
لاشياء بسيطه في ايران
ولكن جميله جدا
الحمراء همم
كتابات العربيه
اكثر من اشياء كانت مستوره في اسواق
الاوروبيه من قبل المباراه همم دكتور
دكتور
السياسه
في المرحله
[موسيقى]
القيصريه روسيا القيصريه روسيا السوفيتيه
وروسيا الاتحاديه الوطنيه لم يتغير شيء
يتغير ولكن كل هذه التغيرات
اا توقيت عندنا نحن فوق السياسه
ولكن من اجل الثقافه
هل هناك فتره وقع ضرر على الارميتاج نعم
هناك في كثير من اشياء مثلا في بعض الثوره
كانت هناك فكره الديمقراطيه اشتراكيه ان
هناك
جدا
ممكن نستخدم هذه التعليم
ولكن الناس كل الناس هذه انتهوا في
المعسكر ذلك
كانت فكره اولا نحن نوزل اللوحات من
الانمي كثير من المتاح
واعمله هذا وبعدين كانت الفكره الثانيه
ممكن ممكن
شويه فلوس نستفيد منها نستفيد منها واذا
همم
اشياء ثمينه ثمينه جدا سمينه جدا 20 من
احسن لوحه فيه همم
متحف الوطني للاندرويد
في
امريكا في امريكا وهذا الوزير المالكه انه
امكانيات لي افتتاح كثير من الابواب في
التجاره
لان هذه الصفقات
[موسيقى]
الساحره التي تعد احدى اكثر الوجهات
السياحيه جذبا في روسيا يقع متحف الارض
نتاج العريق الارض ثاني اكبر المتاحف في
العالم بعد اللوفر ويضم ملايين القطع
والتحف الفنيه النادره التي تعود الى
حضارات وحقب تاريخيه مختلفه
[موسيقى]
يعود بناؤه الى عام
1764 بامر من الامبراطوره كثر الثانيه
المعروفه باسم كثر العظيمه واليوم بات
المتحف يملك فروعا خارجيه في كل من هولندا
والولايات المتحده الامريكيه وايطاليا
المتحف المسكون بقصص التاريخ وجمال
العماره يستقبل كل عام مالا يقل عن ثلاثه
ملايين ونصف مليون زائر وهو مؤلف من خمسه
اساسيه هي القصر الشتوي الارمنتاج الصغير
والارمنتاج القديم والارميتاج الجديد
ومسرح الارمنتاج
[موسيقى]
الاستشراق يطرح دائما اشكاليه اشكاليه
ثقافيه سياسيه يبدون العرب لديهم حساسيه
بسبب ارتباط ذلك مع النشاط الاستعماري من
قبل الدول الغربيه الواجهتك هذه المشكله
حينما قررت ان تدرس او ان تتخصص في العالم
العربي دراسات العربيه
الفتره الاستعمار كان الفتره الغزوات
العربيه او الغزوات المغوليه والى اخره
في التاريخ
وتتذكر ان سابقا كان هكذا سابقا
مثلا في روسيا كانت الفتره كان الاول انا
كان البولندا وبعدين كانوا كان الفرنس
لكن لم تكن دراسات الشرقيه الروسيه تمثل
اشكاليه عند العرب يعني بقدر ما كانت
الدرا
نقول الغربيه الانجليزيه الفرنسيه على وجه
التحديد لانها كانت تستخدم كعذال الهيمنه
على على المنطق في الحاله السوفيتيه لم
تكن بارزه بشكل كبير لم تكن بارزه بشكل
كبير لاننا نحن كانوا بعيدين
المنطقه
وكانت دائما دراسات سياسيه ونحن لازم
نفترق ونفهم مع الفرق بيننا نعرف المستشرق
موضوعي دكتور هل هو موضوع علمي في
الدراسات ام لديه خلفيه ماء ايدولوجيا ما
تؤثر فيك دائما ممكن ان نفهم هذا هو نحن
بالاسماء نحن فيه
جيده جدا يعني تفسر همم خلفيه كل من همم
المشتركين باريزين الخلفيه مشاهير خلفيه
يهوديه الحرفيه كسلكيه خلفيه برو
حرفيه خلفيه همم
تركيه خلفيه دائما فيها حلفيه ولكن هل فيه
لازم تكون همم
تتبنى ان الاحترام للناس ان تدرس
هل الدين كان حاضرا في الخلفيه الكنيسه
الارثوذكسيه همم وبيت المقدس مهدي
الديانات هل كان الامر هذا حاضرا في
النشاط السوفيتي همم الاستشراقي في نشات
السوفيه الله قليل ولكن نحن دائما نريد ان
نحتفظ به العلاقات القديمه التي كانت في
هذا الشيء مهم جدا بالنسبه للكنيسه ارتد
كثير روسيه لان علاقات مع الشرق الاوسط
والكنيسه مسيحيه هنا
المسيحيتنا من هنا والامن اوروبا
وكل الوقت مشاكل المسيحيه اليوم في الشرق
الاوسط لان الشيء مهم جدا
وفي فتره السوفيتيه كان كنافس
بجمعيه كانت وسامه بالجمعيه الامبراطوريه
الفلسطينيه
كانت متخصصه في دراسات والعلاقات مرتبطه
بالدينيه مال المسيحيين
فلسطين
ازدهار هذه الجمعيه بالمناسبه لرئيس
الجمعيه في نيويورك
الطرفين المسلمين والعرب والمسيحيين العرب
والروس لديهم قدره اكبر على فهم بعضهم
البعض لديهم شيء مشترك حقيقي وجدي يمكن
التعويل عليه والبناء عليه
انا اعتقد ان بالصوره عامه مسيحيين ولا
مسلمين بالنسبه للمسيحيين هناك في
همم شهر خلاوصه والتاريخ الكنيسه بالنسبه
للمسلمين في
خلفيه ال- همم
وجود المسلمين لفتره طويله في الكثيره في
روسيا والاخير
عندما انسان يريد التفاهم
ما في مشكله
يجد بناء للتفاعل لا يريد تفاهم ما فيش
مشكله يكون لها في هناك الاسباب
هنا وكان الاسلام الديانه الثانيه في
روسيا يساعد ام يؤثر احيانا
اه طبعا ولكن كل هذا ايضا يتعلق
بالانسان بالناس والمثقفين لانه بالثقافه
ممكن ان يكون اساس لحروب الذكريات او حوار
الحضارات انت ممكن تكون
دائما عدوي عدوي عدوي عدوي او تكون عندنا
الحروف وكان هناك ايضا العلاقات والتبادل
همم مثلا همم
الحروف كانت ايضا همم وسيله تبادل الثقافي
الفنون والسلاح المقتنيات كانت عبر الحروب
المعركه في الصباح وكانوا ينزلون ويقولون
في المساء
هذا كانت الفتره القرون الوسطنه في هناك
كتب ممتازه الاسلاميه ان هذه التاريخ ان
هناك في امكانيات التفاهم نحن لازم نعمل
من اجل
تكون تفاهم ممكنا وجينا ما هي قصه دكتور
قصه طرح اليوم الحضاره الوراثيه الثقافه
في في روسيا ومحاوله النظر بشكل مغايره عن
مكانته النظره بشكل يعني باتجاه بعيد عن
الغرب وبعيد عن منطلقات الغربيه
انا دايما موجود
ثابته موجوده في روسيا كان دائما مثل ما
رؤوسنا دوله كانت اتجاه كما بيصرف انا فيه
المهبلي السلفيه
للخصوصيه الروسيه
والجانب الثاني بالغربيين الناس كانوا
يحبوا يكون روسيا جزء من الحضاره الغربيه
الوطنيه متحركه
[موسيقى]
العلميه وفاه احمد الحضاره الاعلاميه ما
هي قصه يقال انه هناك حكايه في الارميتاج
للقطط حكايه قديمه من ايام القياسره كثره
القديمه والخبيسه همم ثمن القطط كانت
موجوده في ارميزات من ايام القياس اللي
فاز على
مقتنيات كل شيء يكون حفاظه اه وبعدين طبعا
كازينا عده القطط كانت موجوده
[موسيقى]
جئت الازمه
واسماء الازمه الناس يتركون الحيوان في
الشوارع مثلا هناك ناس وجدوا قطط صغيره في
الشوارع مبروك
بسم الله اكثر من 50 هكذا
هي موجوده هي موجودين هناك في
القسم خاص لهم احيانا يخرجون الى الشمس
من الماركه القرميتاج الناس يحبون
انا دائما اقول ان عندنا في ناس يطلبون
لقاء الصحفي
القطط اكثر
منها ههه
اسرتك مهتمه بالثقافه والتنقيب والتاريخ
والحضاره منذ عشرات السنين ماذا يعني لك
الارض تاج اليوم حينما تتجول في ماذا تشعر
به
انشر ان هذا شيء ممكن الوحيد اللي موجود
الدائم
موجود
الجديده
نحن رممناه
نحن نفكر
جديده
المعلقات
خاصه
اليوم هذه دقائق هذا المكان اللي معه اكثر
نحن سعداء جدا دكتور ولدينا كثير من
القضايا التي سنناقشها في مكتبكم في حوار
يتناول الحاله الثقافيه والحاله التاريخيه
والحاله الحضاريه والفنيه وكذلك الحاله
سعيد جدا
[موسيقى]
لطالما لاعب المستشرقون دورا محوريا في
رسم السياسات الغربيه تجاه العالمين
العربي والاسلامي بشكل
على الاطلاق اكتسب مفهوم الاستشراق
المغلفي بالكثير من الحركات والدوافع
الفكريه والثقافيه والاجتماعيه حيزن واسعا
من التمويل والتاطير والاحتضان الرسمي من
قبل غالبيه الحكومات الغربيه بهدف في
ترسيخ سوره النمطيه المحدده من شانها
المساعده في تحقيق غايات واهداف سياسيه
واقتصاديه بالدرجه الاولى
ورغم مرور زمن طويل على الصعود نجمه
واختلاف مذاهبه واهدافه التي ساعدت بطرق
مباشره وغير مباشره ساعدت الخططه
الاستعماريه والمبرياليه فان مفهوم استقر
في مربع الصوره السلبيه القابعه في ذهن
واطن العربي باعتباره جزءا من ادوات فرض
الهيمنه والتعالي والسطو على مقدرات
الشعوب
ما الذي سيطر عليك دكتور بترافسكي حينما
قررت ان تذهب للعالم العربي وان تدرس في
الستينات اول مره هكذا انا كنت انزل انا
ما يعمل والدي والداتي وكنت هبه نكون
متخصص في دراسات تاريخيه الى اثريه
والشرقيه لان الشرق وظريف ولكن لازم اختار
في اي مجال اروح
واخترت الدراسات العربيه لان الدراسات
العربيه واللغه العربيه كالعصب شيء اصعب
شيء اصعب شيء في كل هذه المجموعه اللغات
الشرقيه اصعب من حيث اللغه اللغه
كان الانسان انه يعرف العربيه
لا يعرف
لان هو اللي اكل يعرف المصري القديم
والعراق القديم وكثير من اللغات واللغه
العربيه وهو كان لا يعرف
ذهبت الى الجنوب اليمن
ودراسه اللغه العربيه
الكليه الشرقيه
لان اليمن في كل العالم العربي كان همم
اذا كانت البلاد والتاريخ
اقل معرفه ودراسه في هذه في وقت وممم
وعندما جيت انا واتمنى بعد اربع سنوات همم
جئت اني الى جامعه القاهره ودراسه السنه
في جامعه القاهره وبجعد القاهره وبعدت ان
انا ادرس المخطوطات اليمنيه حول تاريخ
اليمن هذا الدكتور خليل يحيى نعمه
والاخرين
واختار دراسات اليمنيه كجوز من دراسات
العربيه كيف رايت العرب في تلك الفتره ذهب
في الستيني
رائد جمال عبد الناصر كيف هو كان يخرج من
جامعه الحسين في رمضان
كل هذا الجو همم قمر ناصر
اهميه المصري اللي كنت تدرس في مصر
اهميه الجمال
في مصر ولا مهم جدا
المخطوطات في جامعه الدول العربيه
سنه الدراسه في مصر كان مهم جدا بالنسبه
للعالم المباراه
العربيه وكتبت الاول الكتاب والدراسه كان
اهل
القصص والصغير اليمنيه عن اليمن القديم
وانا كتبت الكتاب وهذا بعد ما خرجت خرجت
من
جامعه العلوم دخلت معهد الدراسات الشرقيه
والان يسمى بمعهد المخطوطات والشرقيه لانه
فيها مجموع كبير من المخطوط الشرقيه
وانا بدات انه تخصص في دراسه هذه
تاريخ اليمن القديم وقصص عن تاريخ اليمن
القديمه
الاسد
وهو مصممه في القران الكريم ولا كتبت
الكتاب عن مقارنه بين النقوش القديمه
ومختلفه القصص موجوده في
الاخبار
يعني القران الكريم
مقالات عن الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم
طبعا انا كتبت له همم
السياسي واو
وصول العربيه اللي الحضاره الاسلاميه
ان الجزيره العربيه كانت حضاراتها اساسا
لواحد من اسس المهمه جدا للحضاره
الاسلاميه وغير مدروسه بشكل جيد الان بعد
30 سنه ممكن يكون انا اصبح مدروسه لان
كثير لكن
الحضاره العربيه الجزيره
اساسا الحضاره الاسلاميه
والموضوع الذي قمت بدراسته وتخصص فيه يعني
احببت هذا طبعا
اي دراسات دراسات في قولوا لهم الانسانيه
لا يمكن ان تكون يعني همم
بالحب لهذا ولي لانك هذا المكان هذا طبعا
يعني العمل كثير جبار ولكن هذا هذا الزاني
مهم جدا يعني يمتاز همم يستفيد الانسان
يحب كل هذا
دخول عمق المعلومات ودراسه واا مقارنه بين
مختلفه والمصادر وتكون ما هي همم واقع
خلينا نعرف ما هي الواقع ولكن الواقع في
عيون الناس صحيح ههه
بالنسبه للجنوب بالنسبه
همم عمليه تحويل
التاريخ الى
سوره التاريخ لان هناك في التاريخ القديم
وهناك في الصوره التاريخ في اعيننا وفي
من هذا الشيء مهم ايضا في ارميزات كل همم
معرض في التاريخيه هي ان تطوير المنزل
صوره التاريخ من الجهه المختلفه وبعض ذلك
يعني رحت الى زرت اليمن الجنوبي اليمن
الجنوبي اولا مترجم
وبعدين هذا الشيء مهم جدا كانت تاسيس
اليمنيه السوفيتيه في جنوب اليمن في
حضرموت يوصل كبير جدا في خادمه العلوم
موجوده يعني ما كانت موجوده قبل سنه ولكن
في هذه الفتره كانت في الثمانيات كانت
كبيره جدا
خفريات لمختلف المناطق في
حضرموت داخل والساحل
وهذا الدكتور انتباهي مثلا
طرحت احتجاج على فكره مفهوم المستشرق
هذا هذا النشاط في تلك الفتره كان في سياق
سياسي ايضا في سياق اهتمام الاتحاد
السوفيتي
كدوله عظمى تتطلع للخارج كانت تدعم هذه
العيشه صحيح صحيح صحيح
وليس صحيح في سوره كامله الصحيح ان عندنا
فيه هناك تطورات سياسيه نحن العلماء
والعلماء في الانسانيات لازم نستفيد من
هذه الاشياء لتطوير الدراسه لان نحن نريد
كما قلت هذا المهم كان مهم جدا ندرس
ونشترك في دراسه الحضاره اليمنيه القديمه
حضاره العربيه القديمه القديمه كيف لازم
انه نظم البيئه
سياسي والاقتصادي في الامارات العربيه
دراسات علميه نحن نريد ايضا نشترك وهذا
يكون مفيد لكم ومفيدا بسرعه لان في راي
العين مهم جدا اهم من السياسيات ادوارد
سعيد انا لا اريد ان اتجاوز موضوع
الاستشراق دوار سعيد يطرح موضوع حول
الاستشراق وهذه المساله اريد هامه ورد
اتناولها معك طبعا هو هو هو يطرح عده
اشكاليات تتعلق به اولا استشراك كاداه
ايمن السياسيه همم التصورات التي تتبع ذلك
عن استشراق عن بالذات المسلمين والشرق همم
الاوساط النظره للاخر على انه ادناه منك
هل توافق بور سعيد في هذه الشهاده
كان لا يعرف شيء
دراسات الشرقيه في روسيا ويتحدث عن الغرب
لانه كان لا يعرف
شرقيه موجوده
الشرقيه في في الثلاثه
اول شيء هو همم دراسات عالميه بحث
للعلم لا لا نزل عليه السياسه الثاني ايضا
في فروع العلم له
مصادقه الدوله في سياسه في سياسهم في
الخارج اللي فاهم اللي يكون الدوله سياسه
الدوله همم اكثر مفهومه لماذا يعمل هذا
ممكن يكون ايضا ايجابيا او غيره
والثالث هناك في دعايه في دعايه دينيه هذا
مثلا كان ايضا في روسيا الدعايه الدينيه
دراسات العربيه ضد الاسلام دراسات البوذيه
ضد البوذيه هذا دراسات هذه اتجاه دينه هذه
ثلاثه اتجاهات موجوده وهذا لازم الانسان
يفارق بينهم كل الاتجاهات كانت موجوده في
روسيا
وووو دينيه هل تم خصوصيه تتعلق بروسيا
مقارنه بالغرب مقارنه بالدول الغربيه
مقارنه بالنشاط الغربيه
تاريخيه روسيه اسلاميه
والجانب كبير والجوز كبير البوذيين والى
اخره وهناك نحن لنا نشرنا من جديد همم
مجلد من دكتور همم دكتور روز هو كان مؤسس
الدراسات العربيه في روسيا كان في قاره ال
19 من جزء من تراسه كبير الى النشر من
جديد كان النقد على دراسات الاسلاميه كانت
موجوده في خزان من جانب
العلماء اللي كان لهم هذه الدعايه كانت
كانوا يدرسون الاسلام من اجل الدياي ومن
اجل نهايه المسلمين
لخروج من الاسلام
لا يمكن ان تسمى عالميا هذا التاريخ لا
يمكن استخدمه عندما تدرس الحضاره لازم
يكون هناك
ناس يختارون
وهذا التاريخ هذا التقليد مهم جدا
هذا موجود في كثير في وسيله
رؤوس كل هذه العلماء في
نهايه القرن التاسع بدايه القرن العشرين
كانوا
بازل الجهود كبيره لتعليم الناس في روسيا
ضروره الاحترام والاحترام لازم يكون
احساسا لكل الدراسات
يلفتني دكتور باطراف اهتمام عظماء الادب
الروسي بوشكين تولستوي جوجو همم كلهم
تحدثوا عن الاسلام واهتموا به وانعكس
اهتمامهم بالاسلام او بالحاله العربيه على
على انتاجهم تحديدا تتحدث عن النبي وعن
عظمته وعن حكم في شعره همم كتب احسن شيء
اللي كتب كقليد للقران الكريم في خلال ليس
ترجمه هذه محاكاه في القران الكريم هذا
احسن شيء موجود خارج اللغه العربيه
همم
ممتازه ممتازه لانه هو كان هو كان انسان
هو كان النبي هو كان يفهم
الالهي لانه هو الشاعر الكبير
افكار خاصه صلاح يعني
جيدا عن النبي محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم
المسلمين في السجن
في السجن
الاحترام عن نفسيه الانسان
يجمع الاسلام
الشاعر من كارمن 20
هو كاذب هو ولد في اسرع خانه لفوقا وعندهم
في
شرم ممتازه عن
حياته
هذا اسم مدينه استرا خان في الجنوب
ان المسلمين هم نفسه الروس لان الروس
عيونهم شويات
مثل هذا يعني طبعا انا ما اقدر اترجمه
اللغه الروسيه عن الروسيه والاسلام ولكن
ايضا هو كان يكتب ان في هناك الحروف
بيننا نفهم
في مشاكل ولكن هناك
في الجانب الاخر
الحموي وابن الوردي والمقدسيه يتحدث عن
تاريخيا اقصد كام مؤرخي رغم هذه العلاقه
وهذه الجسور الواصله بين الروس والعرب
والمسلمين ورغم ان الاسلام هو ثاني دين في
روسيا وعدد المسلمين ايضا كثير في في
روسيا هناك دول كان ضمن الاتحاد السوفيتي
مسلمه بالكامل لانه في تظله هناك اشكاليه
يضل هناك نوع من الصراع انت نظريتك ترى
انه لا يجزي الصراع بين الكنيسه وبين
الاسلام هل تعتقد انه في في شيء لم يحل في
هناك مشكله ما بين المسلمين والروس
المشاكل
من مشاكل
كنيسه روشه
اختار همم
خلاف اول صداقه مع الخطيئه الذهبيه
ولما العلمان فكان يحارب الالمان وكان امل
وقت مع قطر المسلمين
هناك في قصه بطرس الاول وكاترينا الثانيه
لطريق الروسيه في تطوير العلاقات البطرس
هو كان ااا وكنا زين كبير
هو كان بسيط كل المسلم يذبح مسيحي وهو كان
يكون ولي لازم السياسه الاجباريه بطرس
الاول ولذلك غير معروف في اليوم وعندما
كان يريد ان يعطي ايام الحاليه للقذان
تمثال بطرس
لا نريد بتاريخ ههه
الثانيه
اداره المسلمين ولكل الاديان تاريخ كل
الذي ينتقل اليه في روسيا ادارات وتم هناك
تنظيم هذه الطريقه الروسيه اني تقسيم
الدينيه والثقافيه كما تريدون بس السياسه
الخارجيه والحروب
والفلوس والاخير
اداره الدوله التاريخ
[موسيقى]
احسن من ايه بلدان الاخرين
يطرح دكتور الان الحضاره الوراثيه وانه تم
اختلاف يتعلق بسواء بالرؤوس او بالصينيين
حضاره الشرقيه او حتى بالهند وامكانيه
بناء على الكسندر دوغين يتحدث كثيرا عن
هذا الامر وبالتالي انه كان روسيا لديها
التباس حوله هويتها هي جزء من الغرب وهي
احيانا لا تريد ان تكون هذا الجزء هل هذا
الامر يشكل حاله اليوم اه طبعا
لانه
ممكن نختار الاتجاه الى الغرفه يعني
همم اثار منغوليه في روسيا كنا نتكلم عن
الواحد همم همم امير واختهم سكين هو كان
في فتره نيكولاس الثاني من اولى همم
المتخصصين في تطوير العلاقه على
الدبلوماسيه الروسيه جانب الغاره نحن
دائما الجانب الشرق جانب الشرق نحن دائما
بين الشرق والغرب ونختار هذا وهذا ولذلك
نحن عندنا الطرق الجديده والاستفاده من
الامرين والاستفاده
اين يتجه غربا ام شرقا اه يوم غربا اليوم
شرقا اه ده امير روسي هذا الشيء
عندنا سبورت
وكلنا نحن ضمير منقسم
متحرك
المشاكل ما كل الاختلاف نحن في امكانيه
عندنا في امكانيه نفسيه نفسيه نفهم نحترم
يمكن
الرهان عليه عربيه دول ممزقه حروب اهليه
دول يعني انظمه استبداديه طبعا سنتحدث عن
تاثير روسي ايضا في ذلك لكن قبل ذلك لا
شيء يراهن عليه الان تاريخ العرب تاريخ
عظيم متقدم ساخر لكن الواقع الحالي للعالم
العربي هل هناك شيء يعول عليه يمكن الرهان
عليه
طبعا
خلينا نتكلم عن الجانب الثقافي نحن اليوم
نرى نشاء متاحف الجديده جديده ليس فقط
جديده جديده
[موسيقى]
لكن اصبح ممكن
المتاحف في قطر في قطر فن الاسلامي ممتاز
ايضا عندما هذا العمليه بدات ان كنت كلنا
كنا نفتهر في نفتكر في
العالم انه لا يمكن الان اجمالي مجموعه
جديده كبيره من الفن الاسلامي كل موجود في
المتاح
ما هو الفرق بين الانسان الثقافه السياسه
موجوده عند الحيوان نفس الطريقه
تتحدث دائما
اهتمام الناس بالمتاحف ربما اصبح اقل كانك
تميل للحقبات القديمه والدوله السوفيتيه
التي كانت
تنظر باعتبار وبالتقدير لهذه المسائل
تغيرت الامور معكم
الامور تغير وعلينا ان نتغير معلومه نتكيف
لان في كل التكيف ونستخدم الامكانيات لان
هناك في مثلا في فتره السوفيتيه كانت
تمويل صعبت من الدوله موجود
من الخارج في فتره الجديده الفلوس من ال-
الطويل
كم حجم الميزانيه
ثلاثه مليار
منها النصف من الدوله والنصف منها
العمليات التي ناخذ فلوس لهذا وهذا
المشكله
يصبح النشطاتنا اقل ولذلك يعني الجزء
النصف من الدوله موجود ونستون اصبح ازهار
الحاليين المؤمنين بالامتاج بالثقافه
بالتاريخ بالفن
اه نعم ممكن ترى صور للسياسيين هنا
والصوره احيانا فقط
رئيس الدوله واحد من الصحفي صار منه كيف
انتم في كريم لين كل هذه الاشياء الكبيره
كل هذه الزحف ههه
الضيوف وكان يستخدم
همم مناقشات والحوار دائما وهذا انا اعتقد
هذا الشيء مهم جدا لانه يفهم ان هذه
والمتحف جيد
لبناء نقاش لقناقش انتم خبته للمجلس الدوم
الدكتور بيت راس كبير لكنك
[موسيقى]
ظريف ايضا كيف انا انا وليس عدوا
ولكن طلبوا مني مره ثانيه ان يكون اسمه في
جدول
راسيه ان قصائد باسمي
لهذه الحزب اعتقد ان هذا حزب لا باس به
احسن من كل لحظه اخرى الموجوده في بلادنا
الرئيس
الروسيه
اسمه هذا شعار كان موجود في روسيا دائما
روسيا هي الموحده للمقص الان
لماذا طلبوا مني ان يكون في هذا
مثل الجدول الاستفاده من اسمك الاستفاده
من باسمك لماذا ايش الاستفاده اسم همم
مدير المتحف
السبيترز بورك انا مدينه الذي فيها الرئيس
او الرئيس
لا هو اهميه كبيره لان هذه الناس متخصصين
في تكنولوجيا السياسيه هم عنده
ارقام جيده وانا يعني ان الرئيس
السلامات في مدينه بيتر زورك شخصيه جدا
مهمه اهم من السياسي وهذا الشيء يريد ان
يكون في كل الالم الثقافي مهم من السياسيه
في انتخابات وانا كمان في اشترك فيها عشان
تشوفي نشوف كيف يكون ماذا يكون مهم
بالنسبه لي اتمنى الريتاج هو الاهم هذا هو
الاهم ما هو مستقبل الاارميتاج او الخطط
التي تنظرون او تعدون لها في الارباج
في الثلاثه جمالك عندنا في مشروع
الكبرى همم ثلاثه جوانب اولا همم
افتتاح كل الخزانه نحن وبعدين نحن بنينا
ثلاثه مباني فيها خزانه ريتاج مفتوحه ان
كل الاشياء موجوده في الاربيتاز ليست حامل
الاشياء كلها كيا هي ممكن ناس ينظروها في
هذه المباني الخزانه المفتوحه الشيء
الثاني انا موجود موجود ارميتاج عالميه
نحن عندنا في فروع الارميتاج
والاخرى في مختلف الاماكن
عمليه تقديم همم تراثنا عمليه تقديم اااه
كنوزنا للعالم لا تفكرون في العالم العربي
فرح العالميه قطر الامارات
دول الخليج ودول الكويت عندنا
المعرض الفن الاسلامي في الكويت
مختلفه العراقين الامارات
معروضات مختلفه هو طبعا ما قطر
الاسلامي وافي في الفنان الاسلامي في
الوطن الوطني
صغير جدا شكرا جزيلا لك شكرا جزيلا
[موسيقى]